And who are you?
I'm Ice Cube of the geomitrons, word
My smoke show queen speaks truth
Cool.
Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
This will be my Full Rick and Morty
Season 7 Episode 8 Video
There were a whole bunch of Easter Eggs and references,
so we'll break it all down.
The episode was like a literal sequel
to the Get Schwifty episode,
So not only was a lot of the episode referencing
previous moments from that
episode or previous episodes just in general,
there was a lot of pop culture parodies, too.
Two movies and TV shows like Star Wars, Transformers,
even the Gobots
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the episodes
and care for spoilers
if you haven't seen the episode yet.
We'll start at the beginning.
Work our way through, shot by shot,
talking about Easter eggs in WTF moments
Starting with the episode title
Rise of the Numbericons.
The movie the title is a reference to the Post-Credits
scene from the sketch with the episode
with them bringing back the Ice-T character
who became Water T in that Post-Credits scene.
Generally, the movie itself was meant to be a parody
of like Marvel DC comic book movies,
like really big action movies in their overly plodding,
overly aggressive world building.
And at the time it was a parody of something
that they never intended on paying off,
which itself was a parody of like Marvel post-credits
scenes that never get paid off in.
There have been many of those in the last several years
like there was this vast
Numbericons backstory and Lord that they tease.
But at the time it was a joke
about something that they'd never plan on paying off.
A lot of huge franchises that do that in general too,
like big things that they tease
that you never wind up getting paid off.
But because this episode literally does that.
You could also call this a reference to Rick and Morty
clowning on itself,
turning into the thing that itself has been parodying
this whole time.
there are a lot of other long running animated shows
like The Simpsons, South Park
that get criticized for referencing itself
too much, like previous moments.
Like, remember when the show used to be great,
which they did a lot in this episode?
Remember me?
Kick your ass with the. No.
there have been a number of moments
in the last couple of seasons
where the show itself literally makes fun of itself.
the episode is also notable
in that the real life ice tea person
who was parodied in the original gets with the episode
originally hated the parody.
This time it seems like he's come around on the parody
and he actually enjoys Rick and Morty,
so he participated in the episode playing
water T's Father
Mack McCue,
he even performed a couple of songs during the episode.
magnitude gets a whip like she got to cry.
Y'all people one four feet, that's a python.
There were a couple of big cameos
in the episode, like Real Life Ice-T
that I just mentioned playing his father,
Peter Serafinowicz plays a new American number
eight that rebels against them and becomes infinity.
Also relevant because a large portion of the episode
parodies a bunch of different Star Wars movies.
Peter Serafinowicz was originally the voice of Darth
Maul during Phantom Menace.
Ray Park just did the physical performance
for Darth Maul.
Then when George Lucas brought him back
for the animated Clone Wars
episodes, that's
when Sam Witwer started doing the voice of Darth Maul.
during this episode
and during the original Get Schwifty episode,
the actual water tea character is still voiced by Dan
Harmon.
Keith.
David also came back for new flashback scenes
as the U.S.
president, who at the time was still a governor,
getting ready to run for office unsuccessfully
because it was happening in 1991.
So in real life, U.S.
presidents are limited to two terms,
which is eight years, theoretically,
and he's still the president in present day.
So the timeline wouldn't have worked out
if he'd been the president back in the nineties.
within the episode, though,
they do explain that like there is a reason
why he does not become the president
in that 92 election.
The opening scene is meant to be a reference
to that same post-credits scene from the original
Get Schwifty episode with a few minor changes
in Magma Q's dialog Alphabetrium.
Their planet is a reference to Cybertron water t's
People are more like the Autobots
in this equation during the episode though,
they talk about their common ancestry.
The whole idea is that the Decepticons
and the Autobots are just two factions of transformers
that were created by Cybertron on.
so a lot of the lure of their people
like their shared history that they learn
about during
the episode is a reference to the lore of Transformers.
the funny thing about this is I actually got into
some of this lore during my Transformers videos
when Rise of the Beasts came out,
which you could also say is sort of a reference
to the parody title of this episode,
Rise of the Numbericons like Rise of the Beasts.
the logo and the font are based on the Transformers
movie logo.
The song is a parody of that hardcore Transformers
theme song, which was done by the band line.
The original Transformers movie,
and the theme song just went so hard.
One of the biggest pieces of inspiration for us
was the animated Transformers movie from the eighties,
the color palette, the shot choices.
They really went big in that movie.
if you haven't watched it, it is a rite of passage,
I would recommend checking it out
there are a whole lot of transformers
that got killed at the beginning of that movie.
Just imagine a little kid sitting in the audience
being traumatized by that.
the Numbericons are colored to look like Decepticons.
They have calculator based ships
because they are numbers.
But notice that all the digital readouts
on the calculators read boobs.
it's a very horny episode.
Like there are a bunch of different characters
getting it on with other characters during the episode.
Their world shield is based on brackets
from a normal document.
Brackets are used for isolating text in factoids
inside documents, but in the context of this
episode is literally isolating their planet
also notice the surface of their planet.
You can see all the giant land
masses are just big letters.
his glyph jumper ship seems like a parody
of the Transformers original spaceship.
The Interior also feels like a reference
to the layout of Karl Kesey's spaceship
during the Jedi Survivor games.
Maybe a little bit Millennium Falcon, too,
because of all the Star Wars parody During the episode
In documents, glyphs are meant to be symbols
representing different letters and characters.
the whole I of harmony is meant to be a parody
of the matrix of leadership
from the original Transformers movie.
Then coming to Earth is also a reference
to the Transformers coming to Earth during that movie.
it's a big Goldenfold episode
who they reveal a bunch of backstory for.
He used to be Water T's teacher
when he was exiled to Earth in his human form.
And in present day
because of what happened between them.
He hates hip hop music, yelling at Morty.
notice the kids sitting in front of Morty
in class is also a parody of Justin
Roiland in real life,
but he's been in Morty's class in season one.
Like he's been around for a long time.
Goldenfold being Water T's former teacher
also trying to teach everyone math all the time
during the episode seems like a reference
to the Edward James Olmos movie Stand Deliver,
which was all about him
trying to teach inner city school kids calculus.
Ice-T was also on the famed TV series back
in the eighties, which took place out of high school.
You could call it a bit of a reference to that too,
there are a lot of moments during the episode
where they clown on Ice-T, but he's kind of
in on the joke this time because the real life Ice-T
is playing a character during the episode.
Morty makes several, gets with the episode references
during this episode to water tea.
But water tea for some reason
just repeatedly keeps saying that he forgets,
doesn't remember anything about that actual episode.
Like, I don't know what you're talking about. maybe.
Just because he doesn't want to give Morty
the satisfaction, you can let me know in the comments,
like, why did he refused to acknowledge
the get with the episode?
We learned a bunch about Goldenfold back story.
Turns out he loves.
He loves Smokey Robinson
but hates hip hop music, mostly
because of his bad blood with Ice-T or Water Tea,
however you want to think about him it.
Apparently he is super horny on Main,
but I don't think that's a new thing.
I think he's been like that in previous episodes.
he references clown balls.
He theoretically impregnates one of the other simple
ancient glyphs on the other planet.
It also references to numbers and letters,
getting it on all the time.
Like numbers
get down all the time, sometimes with letters
He even talks about during the episode
when they flash back to water tea.
When he was in class.
He's got a Sony Walkman and he's
wearing a Pac-Man T-shirt because it is in the 1980s.
Sinister seven is mostly a parody of like Kylo Ren
or maybe like an evil version of Rey
because the whole star Wars parody the episode
in the relationship that she gets in with water.
Do you like the villain who turns good,
gets into the relationship with the hero,
then working together to defeat infinity
and Kylo Ren Rey working together to defeat
Emperor Palpatine during rise of Skywalker,
He insults her by calling her an upside down l
because she is literally the number seven.
You turn it upside down.
It looks kind of like an El
if I talked about every single number and letters pun
that they talk about in the episode,
this video would be like an hour long
like she talks about spilling the tea
as in killing water
tea weapons lock for them is called caps
lock like on your keyboard.
The hyperdrive is called the hyphen drive.
They also later call it the Helvetica Drive
when she returns to their mothership.
It's a giant bracket for numbers and symbols.
Also, it's a reference to Darth Vader's
super star destroyer
when her ship flies in
it also makes the tie fighter howling sound.
her father is Lord Dreadnought.
He's a giant zero.
The hologram scene is a parody of that Empire Strikes
Back scene where Darth Vader speaks
to the emperor for the first time.
his little period symbol, cackling and cracking jokes
all the time.
Feels like a parody of salacious crumb,
though Dreadnought is meant to be the Emperor
Palpatine in the Star Wars parody
or this equation to make more math puns.
Several times.
In the episode, Goldenfold keeps referencing the
homework that water tea owes him from a long, long ago.
which he finally completes at the end of the episode?
they climb on Morty for being super dumb, saying he's
literally the worst student Goldenfold has ever had.
Like, no, you're way dumber than water.
He was when they flashback to water
Tes Recording studio.
It's the same one from the get Schwifty episode.
Goldenfold uses
math to teach him how to make his music better
using four
four rhythm time eventually becoming huge hip hop star.
Ice-T like he is in real life,
His audio engineer makes it back to the future
reference with the Marvin Gaye joke,
which Morty then later references again.
Goldenfold realizes where they need to go next
and when he makes the beep boop
sounds himself while typing the keys in the console.
That's also a bit of a meta reference to the actors
in Star Wars, making the sounds of the lightsabers
the blasters in real life, when they're using them,
when they're not supposed to like while
they're actually filming.
part of the whole joke is that there's no actual
sounds like The Blasters don't make sounds,
the lightsabers don't make sense.
They add those in post-production later.
So sometimes the actors will just get so obsessed
with what they're doing that
they'll make the sounds themselves with their mouths
while they're trying to film.
I think planet E ten where God created letters
is meant to be a Star Trek five reference
when they think that they're traveling to the center
of the universe to meet actual God during the episode.
It's also a bit of a reference to Ender from
Return of the Jedi in Diego from Empire Strikes Back.
we meet Oxygen as who is Peter
Sarah Phoenix's character, secretly
the number eight who's infiltrated the Alphabetrium
when he says in quotes
that use a device used in documents
to add context to sentences, he narrates his own reveal
in third person to a couple of times in the episode.
This time, he says, Secret villain.
when they arrive at the planet, notice
the seven calls out to three Isaiah's
Christ like a Jesus Christ based on their new culture,
then crashing in the swamp.
The ship sinking is also from Empire Strikes Back.
They start teasing their relationship together.
Goldenfold gets a little horny, talking about numbers
and letters getting in on, like I said, also
making the reference,
The primitive Googas are also symbols
that are parodies of the Ewolks
and Return of the Jedi.
Goldenfold
also references that literally calling them Ewolks
They reference Star Wars on the show
literally many times before.
So the Star Wars
movies have been canon to Rick and Morty for a while.
their JibJab song is a parody of the Ewok song
at the end of Return of the Jedi.
I Notice they're cannibals.
Kind of like they're eating one
of their own primitive symbols on the spit,
which itself is a reference to
Like, that's what it actually looks like
later in the episode.
You hear them making Cock a doodle Sounds
that Morty figures out,
the primitive symbols are what modern Numbericons in
Alphabetrium came from,
like the shared original language that they're based on
this is actually based on real life
like Arabic numerals in ancient symbols,
based on a common language.
then Goldenfold reveals his full backstory,
the beef that he has with water t
Back in 1991, Water T wins a Grammy for his music.
That's a reference to the real life
iced tea, musician or artist winning a Grammy in 1991.
He also won one in 1992 as well.
we find out the U.S.
president was still governor at that time running for
president in what would have been the 1992 election.
That actually wound up being Clinton's
first win against George Bush.
Senior.
I think part of the joke here
is that the president didn't win that election
because the timeline wouldn't have worked out.
But also in universe.
The logic is that he lost the math vote
that he was hoping to get when water t would have given
math and Goldenfold
A shout out at the Grammys.
Notice
he has a CRT television because it is the nineties.
their number of parodies of real life
celebrities at the Grammys, their Will Smith.
Because in 1991, he released summertime
and with DJ Jazzy Jeff as a single.
So he was at the Grammys that year.
Dumpty hump was the alter ego of Shaggy,
who in 1991 released The Sons of the P album,
which actually kind of flows with the parody
of the whole numbers and letters during the episode.
Dr. Demento was just a radio deejay and a comedian
who released a greatest Hits album that year in 1991.
there we see water t and seven finally get it on.
They both had that psychedelic mind trip
similar to the one that Rick and Jerry
had during season three, where they both see the races
did have a common ancestor in the primitive symbols,
I guess you could call this the draw here.
Like the thing that they stick the key
into sort of a Rosetta stone
that explains the origin of their collective languages.
Number eight then reveals his betrayal.
His cybernetic parts are a Darth Vader
reference with his burnt looking face to Notice
that his droids kind of seem like souped up
versions of the butter robot.
he narrates his own action again
in third person saying villain exit.
then we get water t's side of his beef
with Goldenfold their history together
learning that his father played by actual ice T
in real life called him a traitor
to his people for loving numbers
when he used the four four time for his music.
And that was the reason why he didn't give math
or Goldenfold shout out at the Grammys.
one, Number eight usurps
and then kills Laura Dreadnought.
That feels like a reference to Darth Vader
killing the Emperor.
In Return of the Jedi.
He evolves into infinity.
Mordi. Then references Get Schwifty again.
But even though he changes back to Ice-T,
he claims he still doesn't remember it.
like I said, many references
to get Schwifty during the episode.
But each time water t claims he doesn't remember it,
the more he is saying they should lift their ship
out of the swamp and upgrade.
It is also a reference to Yoda using the force
in Empire Strikes Back to left Luke Skywalker's X-Wing.
they even give it a joke about product integration and
selling toys, calling it the new extreme glyph jumper.
Like you have to buy it now
with the in universe toy commercial.
That's also meant to be a parody of most eighties
cartoons just in general, like Saturday morning
cartoons which are mostly remembered
for being like 30 minute glorified toy commercials.
that's one of the reasons in real life
we don't have Saturday morning cartoons
the way we used to have them
because there was a lot of regulation that said that.
No, no, no, no.
You have to be careful
about the way you market stuff to children.
Now, Rick and Morty has parody
this phenomenon many, many times,
like a really good example of the in universe
toy commercials are the story train episode.
then infinity killing both the Numbericons
and the Alphabetrium on both sides of the aisle
is another reference to Emperor Palpatine.
During Rise of Skywalker.
We started using Force Lightning.
He basically started hurting his own star destroyers
in addition to the resistance fleet.
Water t and seven
Working together to kill him.
Also a reference to Kylo Ren and Rey
killing the Emperor together.
Notice of seven and water t
To make a literal reference
to the title of the movie Inside the episode saying
How could the numbericons rise again?
How can they rise up?
Which has been parodied in all kinds of movies
and TV shows like,
my God,
they said the name of the thing inside the thing.
then they basically end the episode
with another version of a Get Swift sequel with them
performing hip hop songs together.
This time, real life.
Ice-T
also sings with them when he comes back as his father.
They also use the same twist and the sketch with the
episode using a song to defeat someone more powerful.
iced tea as magma Q
CU comes back as the force goes pulling
the Luke Skywalker twist from rise of Skywalker.
Like projecting his force spirit.
They make a literal force ghost. Star Wars reference.
Then magma Q crowns water t king
Magma of their people giving him his power,
getting immunity with the cracks.
Also a reference to Star Wars, with Luke Skywalker
blowing up the Death Star.
then when seven says she's only a prime number,
only divisible by herself.
That's just saying that she can't have children
basically in magnetic saying that is junk is magma,
saying that he might theoretically kill her
if they actually did have sex,
then they actually end things with Magneto
finishing the homework that he owed Golden
for this whole time, which he happily
fails him on big time, like he gets off on bailing you.
Like you have no idea how happy I am to fail
you end, during the post-credits
scene,
after a short time jump, there's an Ice Cube parody.
I'm not sure who's playing the character.
It's not real life. Ice Cube playing the character.
But he says in episode in context.
His name is Ice Cube of the geometry lines,
which is a parody
of the Go bots who need help fighting the form of wars.
so. It's meant to be an in-universe
sequel to The Rise of the Numbericons
movie called Challenge of the Geometry.
It's based on the challenge of the gobots TV series.
If you're not familiar with the gobots, most people
think of them as a rip off of the Transformers.
But in reality, the Gobots actually premiered a year
before the Transformers line debuted in 1983.
but even though the gobots debuted in 1983,
they were way less popular.
So everybody just remembers the transformers.
Eventually the gobots just went away
There've been a lot of go back parodies
recently, too, like during the Guardians of the Galaxy
holiday special in the Marvel Universe.
James Gunn made a big go Boss joke.
Apparently Go Bots are just
cannon to the Marvel Universe now
to like they're real beings inside the Marvel Universe.
But there were a whole bunch of Easter eggs
and references and parodies
to a bunch of different things in the episode.
If there are any of the You spotted that
I didn't talk about during the video, just write them
below in the comments in my full Episode
nine video we'll post next week after they release it.
They're only ten episodes total.
Like we're most of the season finale.
really interested to see if they debut
some kind of teaser for like whoever
the next big villain of the series is going to be,
or if we'll just have like a regular old season finale.
the other big thing that's coming up is the Marvel.
What If Season 2 episodes will start around Christmas
week
I'll be doing videos for all of those,
but you get some trailers for that pretty soon.
And because this weekend was CCXP Brazil Comic-Con,
there were a whole bunch of trailers.
click
Here for all those trailer videos and click here
for all my Rick and Morty episode videos.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!